[Musique]
nous devons nous en débarrasser nous avons la
technologie nous avons le vaccin pour que nous puissions le faire
le point est ce que les gens ne
font pas ce que nous n'avons pas pu faire
c'est une question de sensibilisation
[Musique] merci merci
anges
et plus tôt
[Musique]
ma découverte ma seule prise sur ce
trajet est l'histoire du peuple africain
j'ai découvert que les africains sont des
gens sympas les africains sont des gens hospitaliers
[Musique]
eh bien la prochaine partie pour moi est que je roule
à un  date ultérieure,
je roulerai de lagos à israël puis
à travers l'asie puis en gros je me
dirigerai vers le plateau tibétain
puis là je vais rouler jusqu'au
camp de base de l'everest puis quand j'arriverai à everett
biscang je veux essayer de grimper  mont
everest
[Musique]